there's a neat way to convert kilograms  to pounds and pounds to kilograms that  not everyone knows  one kilogram is approximately 2.2 pounds  the technique is to double the number  and add 10 percent  let's try an example of converting 50  kilograms to pounds we double it to get  to 100 then we add 10 percent which is  adding 10. this will be 110 pounds and  it's very close to the exact answer  what if you need it to go the other way  of converting pounds into kilograms  well .454 kilograms is approximately one  pound so the technique is to have the  number and then subtract 10 percent  let's see how this works with an example  of 25 pounds  we have the number to get to 12.5 and we  subtract 10 percent which is subtracting  1.25 this gives 11.25 kilograms which is  a great approximation this is a neat  trick and you can use it every day